Jensen Jen-hsun Huang has recently become popular
The whole world is talking about him
Wow, hair is all white.
They all said he was so handsome
That's right
He returned to Taiwan to get his hair done
Specifically told the designer
Don't dye it black
I want to look like
what I should look like
at my age.
Not dyed black
Instead, it became his trademark
Ha ha ha ha
I am also a fan of not dyeing black
Old Chinese doctor with white hair
Just like a Kung Fu master has a white beard
You can tell he has experience.
Have nèi gōng (transliteration)
Hu Naiwen starts his lecture
I'm your old friend, Dr. Hu.
I want to share this episode with you
How much hair loss is normal?
What is the reason
3 foods to nourish hair
1 acupoints to promote hair growth
Black hair grows back
The real problem of gray hair is
kidney deficiency and blood deficiency
Gray hair doesn't just mean you're old.
It could also be
Predictions of cardiovascular disease
A European study of
more than 2,000 people found
If a person has obvious white hair
before the age of 40
His risk of cardiovascular disease
That's five times the average person's
Gray hair is not just about aging
It's a warning from the body.
Wow, five times
That's very high
Why is it easy to grow white hair
In the knowledge of traditional Chinese medicine,
Gray hair is often related to these three reasons
Kidney deficiency, blood deficiency,qì zhì(transliteration)
1. Kidney deficiency
Shèn cáng jīng zhǔ gǔ shēng fā(transliteration)
Shèn shì xiān tiān zhī běn(transliteration)
Many Chinese medicine books talk about
Fà wèi shèn zhī huá(transliteration)
I specifically cited the yī zōng jīn jiàn (transliteration) to say this:
What does this sentence mean?
It means that the kidney qi is sufficient
The hair is black and thick
Kidney Qi deficiency
The hair becomes thin and soft
It also becomes dry and turns yellow
Even premature hair loss
How to know if you have kidney deficiency
Have you ever
Back pain and memory loss
or getting up to go to the bathroom frequently at night
Then you have to pay attention
Maybe it is
Insufficient kidney qi, kidney deficiency
2. Blood Deficiency
Fà wèi xuè zhī yú(transliteration)
Xuè bù yǎng fà(transliteration)
Hair loses its luster and turns white easily
What are the symptoms of blood deficiency?
Pale complexion and easy fatigue
cold hands and feet
Poor sleep and hair loss
Have symptoms like this
It's a warning sign of blood deficiency
Once blood is deficient
Hair follicles are like dry land
If there is not enough water, black hair will not grow
Hair loss followed.
3. qì zhì (transliteration)
It's just emotional stress
Liver qi disharmony
Modern people
often feel depressed and stressed
qì jī bù chàng(transliteration)
Gān qì yù jié xuè xíng bù shùn(transliteration)
It will also affect the hair
How to know if you have qì zhì (transliteration)
Often depressed
Sighing and chest tightness
Pain on both sides of the ribs
Girls will experience irregular menstruation
Qì yù jiǔ liǎo bú shū chàng(transliteration)
Hair naturally lacks shine
Hair follicles do not receive enough nutrients
Hair color becomes lighter and whiter
Even severe hair loss
Press 1 acupoint every day
Let hair grow back
To improve hair loss
From white to black
There is an acupuncture point called
Tóu píacupoint(transliteration)
Pinch this acupointevery day
Tap yourTóu pí (transliteration)
Stimulates blood circulation in the scalp
Helps you grow hair
White hair turns black
Tóu píacupoint(transliteration)
Is it on the scalp?
Not on the scalp
It's on your ears
ear
The edge of the ear
This ear
This is called an earlobe, right?
The edge of the earlobe
There is a acupoint in this place
calledTóu píacupoint(transliteration)
You use your right hand toTóu píacupoint(transliteration)
When pressing the rightTóu píacupoint(transliteration)
You hit your scalp here with your left hand
That same
When you press theTóu píacupoint(transliteration)on the left
You use your right hand
Hit the scalp here
Then like this
Press and tap
Press here and tap here
Just knock, knock, knock
That's it
This way you can
Stimulates blood circulation in the scalp
It also activates hair follicles
How long should I press it each time?
It is recommended that you press once a day
One minute each time
After washing your face, you can
Or when watching a drama
It's the time when you relax
To perform this pressing and stimulation
Long-term stimulation of scalp acupoints
Promote blood circulation in the scalp
Make nutrients easier to enter hair follicles
Can be effective
Improve the problem of gray hair and hair loss
How much hair loss is normal every day?
What causes hair loss?
According to the American Academy of Dermatology
It's called the American Academy of Dermatology
He said that each of us has hair loss
If one day falls
50 to 100
That's still within the normal range.
What is the cause of hair loss?
There are 10 common reasons
1. Stress and emotional factors
2. Malnutrition
3. Irregular lifestyle
4. Side effects of drugs
5. Excessive dyeing and perming
6. Immune system disorders
7. Scalp infection or skin disease
8. Genetic influence
9. Hormone imbalance in the body
10. Recovery period after surgery or serious illness
Three magic weapons for kidney nourishment
Nourishes the kidneys, darkens hair and resists aging
Eat right, press often.
Just the basics of hair care
The next step is the key
to truly recovering from the root cause
Kidney tonification
Especially kidney deficiency type hair loss and gray hair
This type of person?
have to start by tonifying the kidneys.
Now we would like to introduce our
Three Treasures for Kidney Nourishment and Black Hair
Polygonum multiflorum, black sesame, black beans
Black food can enter the kidneyjīng (transliteration)
Zī bǔ shèn jiān gù xiān tiān zhī běn(transliteration)
xiān tiān zhī běn(transliteration)is the kidney
Traditional Chinese Medicine says that the kidney isxiān tiān zhī běn(transliteration)
All three are black
Black food
Which organ should be nourished?
I know
Kidney tonification
That's right
Combine Polygonum multiflorum, black sesame and black beans
Grind it into powder and mix it into
Three black powder
There are three black powders on the market.
You search the Internet
You can check it
Okay, this place
It's three black powder
What about these three black powder?
You use this spoon.
Scoop it up a spoonful or two
Put it in your breakfast
Like soy milk and oatmeal
Add a spoonful or two
Then, stir.
You can drink it now
At night, when drinking hot milk
Also add a little three black powder
You can sleep soundly at night
Restore your stamina
Did you know
Polygonum multiflorum Thunb.
No metal materials can be used
to deal with it
So when we use it here
This is the wooden spoon.
Polygonum multiflorum nourishes the liver and kidneys and nourishes blood and qi
Black sesame nourishes the liver, kidneys and five internal organs
Black beans promote blood circulation, detoxify, nourish the skin and fight aging
Do you know the ancient medical doctors?
Lǐ shí zhēn (transliteration)
How do you say black sesame?
He said in the Compendium of Materia Medica
Jiǔ fú qīng shēn bù lǎo yán nián shén xiān(transliteration)
Eating black sesame seeds regularly can
nourish the liver, kidneys, brain and qi.
Won't age so quickly
What else
also found in clinical practice
Some people dye their hair
The quality of sleep has deteriorated
And it's harder to fall asleep than before
recommend you try three black powder.
Maintaining your body from within
Very simple and convenient
Wow, it smells so good
I smelled it here.
Let me try drinking it.
No way
This is what I'm going to drink
Please speak quickly and carefully
Good, good, good
The audience wants to listen to you
Editor, please prepare a cup for me.
I'm done, have a drink too.
good
Change 5 habits
Save the hairline from receding
and hair loss
What to do?
Let us start from our daily habits
Save the crisis
of thinning hair
5 bad habits should never do again
The more you do, the faster you lose
1. Staying up late
Damage to the liver and kidney, yīn xuè kuī (transliteration)
Gray hair and dry hair are likely to find you
When I was young
To take the Chinese medicine exam
The long-term problem is staying up late to study
High stress can severely damage kidney qi.
didn't take good care of it at that time.
No matter how much you replenish yourself
, you can never return to your youthful state.
But you are still young
Maybe it can be restored with good care
2 Excessive sexual activity
Loss of vital energy and kidney deficiency
It will also cause hair to fall out in clumps
3 Eating too much salt
Too much salt can also damage the kidneys
The hair roots are fragile and keep falling out
Rapid weight loss
This won't work if you don't eat any oil.
5. Eating too many processed foods
Eating raw egg protein
processed foods
High in oil, salt and lacking in nutrients
It will cause aging of hair follicles and scalp inflammation
Eating raw protein every day
will also inhibit your biotin
called Biotin absorption
Leaves hair roots without nutrition
Hair volume cut in half
It is better to eat eggs cooked
Don't eat raw
Prevent hair loss and increase hair growth
3 foods to nourish hair
What to eat to prevent hair loss
Want to prevent hair loss and help hair growth
Supplement these three types of food
Protein Zinc Iron
Category 1: Protein
Protein is the basis for hair growth
What are protein foods?
You can add
Chicken Eggs Beef Pork Salmon
Vegetarians
What can eat?
Tofu, soy milk, edamame, yogurt, and milk
Both are sources of high-quality protein
Lack of protein
May cause hair to become brittle and prone to breakage
Even hair loss
Category 2: Zinc
Stabilize hair follicles and promote protein synthesis
Recommend these foods
Oysters Shrimp Clams Fish Beef
Vegetarians can eat
Pumpkin seeds, sesame seeds, cashews, walnuts, peanuts, etc.
A good choice for zinc supplementation
The study found that people
with alopecia areata and male pattern baldness
Zinc levels in the body are generally low
Zinc supplementation can improve hair loss
Make hair follicles alive
Category 3: Iron
Helps blood circulation in the scalp
Especially women
According to the National Nutrition Survey
He said women of childbearing age
Iron is generally insufficient
If you don’t have enough iron, your hair won’t grow well.
If you don't take good care of your hair, you will lose it.
Recommended foods for you to eat
Pork liver, clams, red meat, Gynura bicolor
dark green vegetables
Spinach and black sesame
Dear fans,
We have opened the membership channel
If you agree with Dr. Hu's promotion of Chinese medicine
The concept of taking care of your own health
Small monthly donations are welcome
Or become a VIP sponsor
With you
We can go further
Thank you so much